there's a really touching story that's
come out of new york and it's a really
touching story
that i think shows us
a new angle
on one of our biggest national problems
here's the story two newborn twins were
abandoned in an alleyway wrapped in
brown paper bags and killed in a rat
infested alleyway in the bronx really
really sad story
cops
found
the babies
they were new they just came out just
newborn babies abandoned in an alleyway
this does happen
more often than people would recognize
and so what the cops decide to do around
20 cops in new york
they
held a funeral for the babies they did
this at eternity funeral service in the
section of the bronx they named the
babies zeke and zane zeke short for
ezekiel means god's strength zane means
god's gift
and it was really beautiful ceremony
okay where these two two babies had a
funeral not not by the parents obviously
who were degenerates and killers but by
by these cops
you know we're told the cops are very
evil you know and they're racist and
bigoted well this is a beautiful
beautiful scene
and one of the lieutenants says i've
never seen a case like this these were
two newborn babies who were full term
and then put in garbage bags and thrown
in a rat infested backyard their little
bodies had fractures this has weighed
heavy on every detective that has worked
on the case
wow yeah it's a it's a horrific case
horrific case but it's not particularly
horrific
the reason it's not particularly
horrific is that this happens
every single day in this country and it
doesn't just happen once a day in this
country it happens on average
2362 times each day
the little newborn baby
abandoned in the alleyway and killed
what do we say one day after birth maybe
on the day of his birth
if that baby
had been killed
a few hours earlier
that would have been not just tolerated
that would have been not just protected
by law that would have not just not just
been conducted in a medical facility
with some guy who has an md doing the
butchery it would have been lauded and
celebrated as a woman's right as
reproductive health is a beautiful
wonderful expression of liberty
and freedom and emancipation
and gender equality
if you want to think about the abortion
issue because i know that there are
apparently a lot more squishes in the
republican party and they're a lot
squishier even than i thought that they
were
just recognize that abortion is this
abortion is
it's not it's it's not even throwing
your kid into an alleyway in the bronx
it's worse than that at least those kids
got to breathe the air and live a little
life for i don't know an hour or so
with abortion it's you don't even get
that
you get
with the true to to use a popular phrase
banality of evil you get a medical
doctor in a fluorescent lit room
performing the butchery to the adulation
and applause of the
population
really puts that in perspective 2 362
times per day
and the cops the cops can't get over
this these are you know this is their
job is to see or awful terrible things
the underbelly of society and they see
this crime in particular and they say oh
my god this is so heinous
that we're gonna we're gonna throw a
funeral for we're gonna actually take
our time and our money and go out and
recognize that we need some
ritual
mourning for this
that's how bad this crime is happens
almost 2 400 times a day i'm so glad you
liked that clip but hold up i need your
help on something
sometimes you may have heard about this
the social media
companies the they don't
they don't love what we say okay and so
one way that we fight back against
censorship is making sure that people
have access to the direct stream the
audio podcast okay you can get that at
apple podcast spot if i stitch your
google play wherever you get your
podcasts
just type in the michael knowles show
subscribe there maybe you listen there
maybe you watch it on youtube maybe i
don't know whatever you want to do
subscribe there make sure you got access
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]